[music playing]
Ryan, Steve, congratulations.
You guys have earned your
spot in the final round
of this competition.
You came here, you made
beautiful blades out of scraps,
and now it's time to send
you back to your home
forges to recreate this
iconic weapon from history.
[music playing]
The nimcha.
Pay attention to
details, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
- Good luck.
[music playing]
STEVE: We're in Omaha, Illinois.
It's raining outside.
It's a good day to work in
the shop building our nimcha.
I'm going to put the fullers
in before I start forging.
[music playing]
My point is going good.
I got it pretty
close to what I want.
My forge is not real long, and
while I'm forging this blade,
it wants to warp.
I don't think I accounted
for the length of this blade,
and the weight.
The ends want to hang out.
I've got a lot of steel there,
a lot of stuff to manage.
That's going to be the challenge
to keep that under control.
Got my blade shaped out,
pretty close to parameters,
so day one in the books.
[music playing]
RYAN: Back at the home
forge, ready to start
beating out this nimcha.
I've never made
anything this big.
I'm used to making three
to five inch skinners,
so it's going to be a difficult
build to keep it straight.
I have chosen a piece
of 5160 spring steel.
I'm very familiar with it,
and it holds a good edge.
As I'm beveling this
thing, the natural curve
is coming into this metal
and making it curve for me.
It flowed in, and
it just worked out.
I feel good at the
end of day one.
My blade is forged out,
parameters are met on it.
Tomorrow, I just got to go
in and go full throttle.
STEVE: It's
beginning of day two,
so we're going to get after it.
Working on my guard
right now, trying
to get a guard straightened
out of a railroad spike,
and using this old hammer.
It needs some maintenance,
so we're just going to make
it work the best we can.
Oh, [bleep].
I think this belt's hitting
this flywheel, knocking it off.
This got me kind of behind.
The hammer just wasn't
performing like it should.
Oh, I see.
That's what that is, duct tape.
Throw some more tape on that.
[music playing]
Let's see.
That seemed to
work a lot better.
End of day two, I feel pretty
good, got my guard done today.
Got it fit up.
I'm pretty happy with
how it turned out.
RYAN: I'm pretty excited of
where I finished up yesterday.
I got all the forging done.
Today, I'm going to finish
grinding and put fullers in it
and get it ready for quenching.
I'm going to take a
lot of the mass out,
but I will leave some
meat on the bones
so it doesn't warp
or twist on me.
[music playing]
Everything's going smooth,
just like it's supposed to.
Now that the bevels are in,
I'm ready to go into quench.
I'm a little nervous
about the quench,
being the long blade like it is.
There's a lot of things
that can go wrong.
[music playing]
I didn't hear no tings or pings.
I feel pretty good about
it, but we'll have to look
and see after it cools off.
And we've got a straight blade.
Perfect.
End of day two, I feel great.
I got the blade quenched.
I got the fullers put in it.
It's turning out to
be a beautiful blade.
STEVE: Day three, feel good.
Right now, it's heat treat time.
It's a little nerve wracking.
You put all this
work into something
and it all hinges
on this one moment.
[music playing]
This is where
things could go bad.
[bleep]
[music playing]
Uh-oh, cover it
up with something.
Outside of the fireball in my
face, heat treat went well.
I had some minor bends,
and I think I can clean
it up good on the grinder.
We're ready to start
on the handle tomorrow.
BRIAN: Today is a day four,
and also, it's my birthday.
I've got to finish cleaning
the guard up on it,
fit it, put a pommel on it.
My brain's running
100 miles an hour,
and I can't figure out how
to get this pommel to stay.
After I sat back and I
figured out how to do it,
I threaded my tang and
screwed my pommel on.
It's going to give enough
weight on the back side,
I think, to balance
this blade out.
Now that everything's
glued together
and everything's
all constructed,
I go to finish sharpening
and polishing my blade.
Now ready to test it and
see what's it's going to do.
[music playing]
End of day four,
and I feel great.
The blade's done,
and I get a surprise
birthday party from my family.
It makes me really happy,
just couldn't be a better day.
I'm ready for competition.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
It's time to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your nimchas will do.
I will take your weapon,
deliver some lethal blows
on this boar carcass.
Ryan, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Make some barbecue cut.
All right, let's try.
Seeing the boar carcass,
I'm smiling from ear to ear.
I wanted to see him cut a
boar carcass in half with it.
I know it's razor sharp.
[music playing]
All right, Ryan,
I don't know what's
a bigger beast, the boar carcass
or your nimcha right here.
This is a heavy sword.
Everything about the weight
that you have on this
allows for a very,
very deep cut,
but it's a lot of work
because of the weight.
It's very forward heavy,
but overall, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Steve,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
I'm excited.
Ryan's blade cut well, so I know
I've got some competition here.
Mine better perform.
[music playing]
All right, Steve, let's talk
about your nimcha right here.
First up, the handle
construction, it's smooth.
It's not blocky, so I like that
you have it ovoid over there
and marries in.
Before I started testing,
your blade had a little bit
kick off to the side.
But after the test,
it stayed the same.
Your edge, with a thinner
profile like that, cuts deep.
Also it is a much lighter
sword than your competitor's.
I can control with every slash.
Overall, sir, your
blade feels good.
It will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength
past, the pillar and pot chop.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge
as well as the overall
construction of your nimchas,
I'll be chopping into
these pots and pillars.
Remember this test
is all about what
the targets do to your
blades and not what
your blades do to the target.
Ryan, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Tear it up.
All right, man.
BRIAN: I know I'm behind
the eight ball right now.
I need to perform really well
in the strengthness test.
Hopefully, I'll pull back
up into line with him
and be evened up.
[music playing]
Well, Ryan, in
the strength test,
the edge that you have on
here took a slight roll.
Like, I can't see it so
much as I can feel it.
The rest of it is
really wicked sharp.
It's still all in one piece.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Steve, you're up next.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
All right, cool.
[music playing]
STEVE: I feel pretty good.
I think my blade cut a little
better than Ryan's maybe,
but he didn't have that
can't and flaw on his blade,
so I think I've got a blade
that will hold up to it.
[music playing]
[bleep], man.
Well, Steve, we
got a problem, man.
When I picked this
sword up, I was excited.
It's nice, light, got
a good shape to it,
but looking at your
steel here, it's
a really big grain in here.
You really could have used more
thermal cycling, I'm guessing.
I don't know how you
heat treated this,
but however you did,
it ended up brittle.
[music playing]
Well, Steve, your blade has
suffered a catastrophic failure
during our strength
test and can no
longer continue with testing.
Therefore, I'd like to invite
you to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's hand,
and then please exit the forge.
[music playing]
Congratulations, man.
STEVE: I'm disappointed
my blade broke.
I didn't want to go out that
way, but it is what it is.
Thank you.
I just must get my
heat treat wrong.
Nobody's fault but my own.
I didn't win the
competition, but I gained
so much more than I lost here.
I'm going to walk away here
with my head held high,
and it's going to make me
a better bladesmith for it.
I've really learned a lot.
[music playing]
Ryan, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that
comes with a check--
go ahead, you can smile--
for $10,000, brother.
Good job.
[applause]
Come on.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
Thank you.
It's not how I wanted
to win this competition,
but, you know, it is what it is.
First thing I'm going
to do is hug and kiss
my wife and love on the
kids and play with them
and get right back in the forge.
There's no sleep for the wicked.
[music playing]